This is something called
an error-correcting code.
So if somehow during transmission
some of the 0s get changed to a 1
or vice-versa, this code
is able to pick up
that a mistake has been made.
Now I'm going to need a volunteer
who's going to be a bit of interference
to scramble my message,
so yeah would you like to come up.
Okay so you're gonna be
a little bit of noise on the line
so what's your name?
– Lauren
– Lauren, okay Lauren,
what I want you to do
is you're going to change
one of these numbers over,
so instead of a 1 it becomes a 0,
so if you look down here Lauren,
it's on the other side
there's a zero okay, like that.
So I haven't memorized this
but I'm going to get evil Andy,
could you blindfold me,
and yeah boo. We want your chocolates.
Anyway he's gonna blindfold me,
once I'm blindfolded I'll turn my back,
just change one number over
and hopefully I'll be able to detect
which number you've changed,
okay.
So blindfold me up.
Woarh, gosh,
that's a bit vicious Andy, gosh.
Okay so when you're ready
you tell me
when you've changed
a number over please.
Just one number.
Okay, right
I'm going to remove my blindfold
and hopefully I can spot
which one you've done.
So as I said I haven't memorised this.
Okay, let's see, right.
Beginning to get a feel for it.
Okay I think that you
changed this number here
Okay, pretty good.
Was that magic?
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, thank you
So how did I do that?
It wasn't magic at all,
it was a bit of mathematics, okay.
So actually the message
sent by the computer
isn't the whole thing but just
the top 4 by 4 block.
So this is actually
the message they want to send,
so I'm going to separate this off.
So the message sent by the computer
is actually this top block here
and the other digits
are used to keep check
of what's happening
inside the message.
and actually at the bottom here
if you look at the bottom column
this number here will be a 1
if there are an odd number of 1s in this column.
Okay, and if there are
an even number of 1s,
so in this column,
I put a 0, okay.
So when you turned
one of the things over,
it didn't check out, so for example
if I turn that over
then I've got, well they're meant to be
an even number of 1s there,
so I know there's a mistake
in that column.
And the same thing
for the rows over here, okay.
Why I'm telling this to you because
you're gonna have a go yourself now
to see if you can
correct a mistake.
Okay, so you can work out
which column is wrong
by checking something
wrong down here,
and which of the rows is wrong.
OK? Want to take on the challenge?
–OK
–All right.
Okay we're gonna blindfold her,
and you can close your eyes as well
if you want to do a challenge.
so let's get you over here, all right.
I won't be so vicious as Andy,
sort of almost took my head off.
Okay and we're also not
going to show the viewers at home
so they can have
a challenge at this as well.
I'm gonna change
one of the numbers over now
yeah cover your eyes, and we'll see
whether you can correct the error.
Okay, I'm done so let's see
whether you can do it.
[LAUREN TALKS OFF MIC]
– Zero is even well done,
something in this column
then is wrong, yeah.
What about the rows?
[LAUREN TALKS OFF MIC]
– That's right, even number of 1s there.
– And it's odd...
– So it's first row...
[LAUREN TALKS OFF MIC]
– Did you change this one?
– No you had the second column,
that's right that's right,
so it was this one exactly right,
so give her a big round of applause
for correcting the error, well done.
[APPLAUSE]
Now you might like to have a think about
what happens if one of these numbers
gets changed on the rows and the columns
which are doing the checking,
you can even correct those as well.
Now error correcting codes like this
are used all over the place
in CDs and satellite communication,
for example when NASA
sends pictures back from outer space
there's a lot of interference,
they use even more
sophisticated mathematics
this can correct one number,
but they need to correct lots of numbers
for example here's a picture
that was sent back
before it was corrected,
this is Saturn, it's pretty fuzzy,
but using the mathematics
and error correction,
they managed to change
it into this – much more crystal clear.